hey youtubers comic-con is this weekend
and I'm gonna be doing a whole bunch of
Marvel videos and a Marvel giveaway so I
wanted to do a big preview for Avengers
and all the spin-off movies and the
stuff they're gonna be doing at that
panel there are a few films Marvel isn't
going to be promoting like guardians but
the big news is is that they'll be
announcing some special casting as well
as some of their mystery movies really
we're all just there to see that
Avengers 2 trailer but I will be
uploading the panel footage be sure to
subscribe to get it it is gonna be a
crazy week but it is gonna be so awesome
so here's what's going on the first
thing most important is that Marvel
panel that's gonna be on Saturday July
26th at 5:30 p.m. Pacific time that's
gonna last two and a half hours
Marvel's is always longer just because
they do more than one movie like last
year they did about 45 minutes for
Winter Soldier then another 45 for
guardians and then the rest for Avengers
2 for that last little teaser this
year's just a little bit different in
that they're bringing ant-man and
Avengers 2 like they're bringing the
cast from both those movies but what is
the big special reveal that they're
gonna do Marvel just announced release
dates for five new mystery movies those
are theatrical movies so we're talking
spin-offs Avengers sequels and new
characters those five movies are on top
of the ones that they've already
announced in Phase three like Ant Man
and Captain America 3 these are the
dates for each of the new ones
July 8th 2016 may 5th 2017 July 28th
2017 November 3rd 2017 July 6 2018
November 2nd 2018 and May 3rd 2019 so
what's the deal with all those untitled
films what Marvel's pluggin announced
three or four of them I don't think
anyone expects them to announce all
seven but it is possible the most likely
movies they're going to announce are
Doctor Strange it already has a director
named scott derrickson but no release
date and they haven't announced who the
actor is the rumored release date is
that July 8 2016 1 making it the first
one after Captain America 3 technically
they have the actor they want and Kevin
Feige said that if he signs his contract
before Saturday they will announce who
it is at that Marvel panel the biggest
theories right now include Benedict
Cumberbatch Jared Leto and Edgar Ramirez
so after that supply announced release
dates for Avengers 3 Thor 3 and
guardians of the galaxy 2 I'm also
expecting them to announce what that
first
movie of phase four is the first movie
after Avengers three there's a small
chance that it could be black panther or
an Inhumans movie that's like a whole
lot of information to dump on Hall H but
that is why Marvel's comic-con panel is
always the best like I said I'm totally
gonna upload it that night so it should
post by midnight Saturday depending on
internet speed the Avengers 2 trailer
that they're supposed to be screening at
the panel is a whole different matter
typically Marvel does not post those
clips online or allow them to be posted
online I'm still gonna do a breakdown of
it no matter what but they do allow it
to be posted online I will add it to my
video so Marvel has this really
ambitious plan for releasing movies
that's gonna talk about during the panel
what they're gonna do or try to do is
release at least one sequel movie a year
and one new character movie a year so
here's a screen shot of that release
schedule again all the unknown movies
spring is always where they put their
biggest ones like the sequels meaning
that the summer dates are probably when
we'll see the new characters but once we
get into 2017 there are three movies so
that will probably be a test to see if
it hurts their box office truly so many
big movies in the same year if it goes
well and yes and totally well of course
they're gonna make a ton of money the PI
start releasing five movies every two
years in addition to the extra Netflix
releases like daredevil and the
defenders so all you wondering about
Black Panther Captain Marvel all those
Avengers level characters we will see
their movies eventually I'm still
expecting the first female driven one to
be Black Widow but I think Captain
Marvel will be the second one right
after that so a big part of the panel is
gonna be dedicated to teasing phase
three because we're basically closing
down phase two with Avengers age of
Ultron previously Kevin Feige has said
that phase three is thematically going
to be about magic something they haven't
really done in movies yet if you
remember though at the end of Winter
Soldier Baron von Strucker said we are
entering the age of miracles he was
talking mostly about mutants that was
just Marvel's way of describing mutant
powers but it could also be used to
describe magic it's no coincidence that
Hydra was tracking Stephen strange I
think it's interesting that Sitwell
didn't say Doctor Strange but that
doesn't mean that in their current
continuity Stephen strange is not
sorcerer supreme so when you think about
Phase three
think about Quicksilver Scarlet Witch
and Doctor Strange they're paving the
way for a multi-dimensional marvel
universe with a giant asterisk
that doesn't mean that they're gonna
jump into the multiverse or any demon
planes anytime soon it just means that
they're building the foundation so that
they might be able to do that someday
Kevin Feige has also spent a lot of
interviews in the last week talking
about dr. strange and a lot of the way
he's been talking about that character
makes me feel like Marvel is gonna
introduce him in an Avengers context
just because in his mind that's the way
the character has been developed in the
past in the comics he's always been a
big part of Illuminati stories and big
Avengers team ups like the really big
ones that's why I totally think that the
Avengers to post-credits scene could be
a Doctor Strange moment they've already
hired scott derrickson to direct a
Doctor Strange movie so we know he's
getting a standalone but if the
president of the studio thinks that the
character needs to be established
through the Avengers and Avengers 2 is
still shooting would it not make sense
to include him in that movie in some way
really that's just a lot of evidence
that they're gonna be spending a lot of
time this weekend talking about Doctor
Strange so I'm really excited for that
the other really big news that they
probably will not talk about this
weekend is the fate of who's going to
direct Avengers 3 there's been a lot of
talk that Joss Whedon might not direct
Avengers 3 he might just write and
produce it the reason people are saying
that is because of the demands of
catering to Marvel's way of making
movies like the whole machine is just
getting tough and Marvel movies have
literally been all he's thought about
for the last three years and however
long it takes to make Avengers 3 that's
exhausting so in a situation like that
Joss Whedon would still have a big say
in what the movie looks like what the
script is and who gets cast in it he
would just get a lot of his free time
back I mean he is a family man he has a
family to take care of if that ends up
happening the person I think that
they'll pick next to direct Avengers 3
is James Gunn I think it's a very clear
choice whenever you guys go see
guardians of the galaxy in a couple
weeks you'll see exactly why James Gunn
is perfect for a big team up movie like
Avengers plus he's way cheaper than Joss
Whedon so there is the question of the
Guardians sequel it's true James Gunn
said that depending on how well
guardians does at the box office he will
direct the second cárdenas movie Marvel
has not confirmed it yet but I'm
expecting them to announce that at the
panel right now the movie is on track to
make between 68 and 70 million dollars
opening weekend and it could go as high
as 80 that's a crazy amount of money
compared that to Winter Soldier which
opened at about 95 million dollars for
the dark world open at about 85 million
dollars but those were both sequels the
first Captain America movie
only earned 65 million its opening
weekend so if guardians actually hits
what they're predicting James then we'll
definitely be doing a sequel that could
make it hard for him to do an Avengers
movie so close to that but it just
depends on scheduling it'll be a little
easier to guess what Marvel is gonna do
once they announce a date for Avengers 3
which I think is gonna happen this
weekend I think it's gonna be that July
2018 date that would give them two
mystery movies to do right after Captain
America 3 and for those asking about Tom
Hiddleston he's not gonna be back until
4 3 he's not part of Avengers age of
Ultron which I also think that they'll
announce at the panel Thor 3 that is and
as for that amazing intro that Tom
Hiddleston did as Loki last year I don't
think he's gonna do that this year
the real reason he was there was because
they were promoting Thor the dark world
a small part of me thinks that James
Spader is gonna do an Ultron voice intro
for the panel they'll do like the Loki
thing but it'll be James Spader doing
creepy Ultron voice that is the coolest
thing I think they could do but let me
know if you have another theory and
here's the details on my giveaway I'm
giving away a Marvel Funko pop figure
all you have to do to participate is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll pick a winner next week you
can pretty much pick any character you
want that's available like Iron Man or
Loki so big reminder Marvel panel is
happening Saturday night I'll be
uploading the panel footage after that
if you want to watch me live tweeted or
follow me on social for updates all
those links are in the description I am
working on a Marvel Inhumans movie video
for tomorrow you can click here to watch
it I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it and you can click here to learn
all about the vision and Avengers to 20
stars other child thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you